good morning believe nation today's
message is contribute to society over to
you Charles Koch the role of business in
society is to contribute to societal
well-being and if a business isn't doing
that it shouldn't be bailed out it
shouldn't be subsidized it should go out
of business it should go broke now
business does so by practicing what we
call principled entrepreneurship which
is maximizing long term profitability by
producing products and services that
make people's lives better while using
less resources and always acting
lawfully and with integrity
now I'm not claiming perfection in that
regard far from it but this is and has
been our goal to which we dedicate major
resources entrepreneurs are in business
to contribute to society it's all about
value the more value that you provide
the more money you're gonna make you
want to make a lot of money as an
entrepreneur you have to provide a lot
of value you want to make more money
faster you got to provide more value
faster and the minute you stop providing
value is the minute that your business
starts to go under and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs you may feel like you're
not getting the money you deserve you're
not making the money that you want yet
and really the sobering truth is you're
probably not providing the value to your
clients and as harsh a reality does that
maybe it's also your recipe for success
right start providing more value to your
clients and you will start making more
money in your business
believe so my question that they for you
today is I'm curious to find out what
change you've made in your business to
increase the value that then correspond
to more business or increase in pricing
and more money in your pockets share
your stories so others can also learn
from your success leave it in the
comments below thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso